KNOWN AS BILLY THE KID.
AS AN ADOLESCENT,
HE STOLE CHEESE,
AND THEN HE GOT ARRESTED.
AND HE ESCAPED
OUT OF AN OUTHOUSE.
THAT'S WHEN HE FELT LIKE
HE WAS AN OUTLAW.
YOU KNOW, THESE--
THESE RANCH OWNERS
AND THESE LAND OWNERS
AND THESE SHERIFFS
WERE TAKING WATER AND LAND
AND MONEY
FROM THE INDIANS,
THE MEXICANS.
AND BILLY THE KID
IS THE KIND OF GUY
THAT WOULD BE LIKE,
[bleep] YOU.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA DO THAT.
I'M GONNA SHOOT YOU
AND KILL YOUR PEOPLE...
BOOM, BOOM, BOOM.
BOOM, BOOM.
AND YOUR SHERIFFS, MAYBE.
PEW, PEW, PEW.
HE WAS LOVED
BY THE HISPANIC COMMUNITY,
AND HE APPARENTLY HAD
A LOT OF LATINA WOMEN
THAT LOVED HIM.
BUT, UH--
[laughs]
- DID HE DATE ANY?
- OH, A LOT OF 'EM.
HE LOVED LATINA WOMEN.
THERE WAS THESE STORIES
WHERE HE KILLED
THESE PEOPLE, LIKE,
UH, JOE GRANT,
WHO WAS THE LOCAL DRUNK,
APPARENTLY, AT THIS BAR.
AND BILLY THE KID
WAS SITTING THERE
AND HE DIDN'T RECOGNIZE HIM.
HE SAID, IF I--
IF I MET BILLY THE KID,
I WOULD KILL HIM
IN COLD BLOOD.
I'D MURDER HIM.
AND HE WAS LIKE,
OKAY.
AND SO BILLY THE KID,
HE SAID,
MAN, I LOVE
YOUR IVORY HANDLE.
AND HE TURNED IT
TO WHERE THERE WAS
ONE BLANK
ON THAT REVOLVER.
AND HE SAID, HEY, JOE GRANT,
I'M BILLY THE KID.
[ominous music]
OH, REALLY?
AND HE WALKED OUT.
AND YOU HEAR--
[click]
AND THEN BILLY THE KID
TURNED AROUND
AND SHOT THAT DUDE
IN THE CHIN.
[chuckles]
I MEAN, WELL,
YOU'RE AN ASS[bleep].
BOOM, BOOM, BOOM.
[playing piano]
AND WHAT'S CRAZY
ABOUT BILLY THE KID,
HE COULD SING IN A WAY
THAT NO ONE ELSE COULD SING.
[singing poorly]
LET'S--TRY THAT.
[gibberish]
[laughs]
[mumbling]
HEY, BITCH!
[laughs]
I'M, LIKE, A BITCH!
NO, YOU'RE NOT.
[laughs]
PAT GARRETT WAS THE SHERIFF
AND SAID,
MY--MY ONE GOAL IS TO GET--
I'M GONNA GET BILLY THE KID.
AND HE HUNTED DOWN
BILLY THE KID.
SO THEY FOUND HIM
IN A FARMHOUSE,
AND THEY HAD THE WHOLE PLACE
SURROUNDED.
ONE GUY CAME OUT AND HE DECIDED
TO GO FEED THE HORSE,
AND THEY SHOT HIM DOWN
AND THOUGHT THAT
IT WAS BILLY THE KID.
AND THEY WERE LIKE, WE GOT
BILLY THE KID, WE GOT HIM.
AND THEN THEY REALIZED
THAT IT WASN'T HIM.
SO THEN THEY REALIZED
IT WASN'T HIM.
AND PAT GARRETT SAID,
WELL, SHOOT THE HORSE DOWN.
SHOOT THE HORSE DOWN.
THERE'S NO WINDOWS.
THERE'S NO EXIT.
AND SO THEY
SHOT THE HORSE DOWN.
AND THEY PUT THE HORSE,
THE DEAD HORSE,
IN FRONT OF THE EXIT.
AND THEY PUT HIM
IN FRONT OF THE EXIT
AND NO ONE ELSE
COULD GET OUT.